well hello and welcome everybody to the
show thanks for watching thanks for
being here I remind you that if you want
to get the whole show and not just a
small sliver of it on Facebook you can
subscribe on iTunes or go to YouTube or
become a premium subscriber of The Daily
wire or you can do all three even that
that would be best of all as you can see
I am doing my best impression of
professionalism today with my with my
outfit I know it's not a very convincing
impression but it's the best I can do
all right I want to talk about first
well I don't want to talk about this but
it's necessary to talk about something
utterly horrific the state of New York
in an act of unspeakable unconscionable
barbarism has made abortion legal
through every stage of development up
until birth which means that now in the
state of New York you can kill your
child you're fully formed fully
developed pain capable infant child even
a minute before delivery now I remind
you that just to put this in context in
New York City the abortion rate is so
high especially among minorities that
more black babies are aborted than born
in the city you're more likely as a as a
black baby in the womb you're more
likely to be killed than to be born
that's just that is how and the rate is
very high among white babies as well but
that just shows you it just shows you
how common abortion is in the state
legislature they're looking at that and
they're saying no that's not enough you
know rate the rates not high enough
there aren't enough dead babies yet so
let's pass this law and that's what they
did
now here's a little bit more from The
Daily wire and Amanda presto Giacomo
wrote a great detailed piece about this
which is up now you can go read it it
says the woman will become an even less
safe place for unborn babies on the in
New York come Tuesday Democrat
legislators are set to legalize abortion
up to birth and remove the fatal
procedure from the state's Criminal Code
altogether with the passing of the
euphemistically named reproductive
health act the proposed legislation
erase erases the current limitation on
abortion in the state which is set at
for weeks the reproductive health acts
states and this is important okay listen
to this every individual who becomes
pregnant every individual by the way
that so not every woman but every
individual in case a man gets pregnant
which of course does happen apparently
these days every individual who becomes
pregnant has the fundamental right to
choose to carry the pregnancy to term to
give birth to the child or to have an
abortion so long as the licensed
practitioner acts in good faith a baby
can be murdered in the womb up to birth
in order to quote protect the patient's
life or health notably the meaning of
the word health is not defined within
the legislation okay so there are a few
things - a few things to highlight here
you're gonna hear liberals latching on
to what I just read there about the you
know protect the woman's life or health
and some of the justifications I've
already read on social media are saying
that well you know really this is just a
it's just abortion is only legal in
order to save the life of the mother
that's also just extreme cases no that's
not true okay that's simply false
this legislation legalizes abortion
through every stage of development for
the sake of the mother's health for the
sake of her life but also her health
health is a very broad term it is an
intentionally broad term and it could
mean anything there's a reason why they
didn't define it they didn't get into
any more specifics so are we talking
about physical health emotional health
the psychological health financial
health well yeah we're talking about all
of the above anything at all the
vagueness of the term leaves it open to
mean anything and that's the point
so you combine the vagueness of this
qualification with the fact that the law
declares abortion to be a fundamental
right for every pregnant individual you
combine those two things and that
clearly means that a woman can get an
abortion at any time for any reason
period that's what
that's what it is the only the only
stipulation is that they might have to
kind of vaguely couch their reason in
terms of health that's all and then they
get the abortion second thing to
remember is that and this is sort of
irrelevant anyway considering that this
law is nothing new with it but the whole
idea that you would need abortion to
save the life of a mother is a total
misnomer okay you do not need abortion
that's it that's a thing that doesn't
exist and I know people will say what
about ectopic pregnancies I'm not
talking about ectopic pregnancies that's
a totally separate issue that we could
deal with and you know I would argue
that treating an ectopic pregnancy is
not the same thing as an abortion
because of the principle of double
effect but that's it that's a totally
separate conversation we're talking
about these are late term abortions
after 24 weeks there's no such thing as
a ectopic pregnancy in its third
trimester that doesn't that doesn't
exist so late term abortions to save the
life of the mother that just it doesn't
exist that's not a thing it's it is a it
is a category that doesn't exist it is
never necessary never ever under any
circumstances necessary to get a late
term abortion to save the life of the
mother never necessary period so anytime
someone says that they say well we need
you know we need to have abortion
through all stages in case of life of
the mother just make sure to correct
them and say no that's false there has
never been a scenario ever in history
ever where a woman in the second or
third trimester needed to get an
abortion to save her life never why well
the reason is obvious okay what kind of
thing could make a later term abortion
necessary just think about what what
might come up that would that would
supposedly necessitate that well there
could be some kind of cataclysmic
complication with the child there could
be a health problem with the mother
there are situations you hear about
the mother is diagnosed with some
aggressive form of cancer while she's
pregnant and she can't treat it while
she's pregnant so you know I've heard
that proposed as an example of something
where an abortion isn't necessary to
save the life of the mother but whatever
the case is all it means is that the
baby has to come out okay it means that
the mother has to give birth just to get
the baby out of her and those sorts of
cases do happen where there is something
cataclysmic that goes wrong either with
the mother or the child and now the
pregnancy could be fatal to both of them
potentially so the pregnancy has to end
okay so what does that mean well as I
said all it means is that the child has
to come out the child has to be
delivered much earlier than expected
then the question is why do you need to
kill the child first why does the
pre-emptive killing of the child
contribute to the mother's health if a
mother is at 30 weeks and something
cataclysmic has gone wrong pregnancy has
to end okay that happens it's a terrible
thing very difficult so you take the
baby out that's all you don't need to
kill the baby first you just take the
baby out either way the baby has to come
out in a late-term abortion okay the way
that this is that these things are
conducted and I hate to be graphic with
you but I think we all should face what
these what these things are and you know
rather than using euphemisms I think we
should be we should be frank and clear
about it so here's what here's how a
late-term abortion is done the baby is
injected while the child's still in the
womb he is injected with poison into his
head or into his torso and then he dies
and then the mother carries the dead
baby around in her body for two or three
days and sometimes it'll you know go
back in the next day and they'll check
and the baby's still alive
and has been suffering all that time and
so they inject him again
and then he dies by the way this is a
her
painful death for the child and a child
in those later stages absolutely can
feel pain there's no question about it
they've got a develop nervous system
they can feel pain and to be injected
with poison into your skull well I don't
think I need to explain how incredibly
painful that would be so the baby is
injected with the poison the mother
carries the dead child around in her in
her body and and then she delivers the
dead child there's there is a delivery
that happens sometimes she delivers the
child in the clinic but then oftentimes
she's not able to get to the you know
labor comes on very quickly she's not
able to get to the to the to the clinic
so she ends up delivering in say the
hotel bathroom into the toilet or
something like that so again the
question is the mother has to go in you
know if the babies if the mother decides
for whatever reason at that stage that
she doesn't want the baby inside her
anymore she's going to have to deliver
the child regardless there is no medical
reason ever why you would need to kill
the baby first you could have just as
well delivered the healthy baby that
that in-between step of injecting poison
into his skull obviously that doesn't
contribute to the mother's health and
obviously it's just another step that's
more dangerous for the mother and
clearly the child as well so the the the
injection of poison into this process
that doesn't make it medically safer for
anybody so again if she's 20 I guy I
just I feel like this needs to be
emphasized because I keep hearing this
and it makes no sense if if she's 26
weeks or 30 or 32 or whatever she could
deliver the child and the child could
easily survive easily the pre-emptive
murder of the child is not ever
necessary for her health ever it is just
murder it is just death it is killing
that's all
I'm sorry to be graphic with you by the
way describing how this happens but I
think it's important to be to be frank
about what we're dealing with not to
cover it in these kind of code words and
everything that the pro-abortion Left
likes to use because they cannot
confront the wickedness of this
procedure that they support and we
should be clear that the state of New
York just made it legal to give a fully
developed infant a lethal injection
that's what happened which brings us to
an interesting point by the way because
let's look at this dichotomy here it is
it is unconstitutional in the state of
New York to give the lethal injection to
convicted criminals they don't have the
death penalty they haven't had it for it
for many years and it's been ruled
unconstitutional so if a man rapes and
murders a child for instance in the
state of New York you cannot give him
lethal injection is unconstitutional
which means that the lethal injection
can only be administered to babies in
New York think about that the lethal
injection is legal in New York but only
if you're giving it to a baby I mean
here's the thing this is why I always
say that abortion is a litmus test issue
not just a litmus test for politicians
although what is that but it's a litmus
test for human beings in general it
tells me kind of like everything I need
to know about you as a human being
because you are just not a decent person
if you support giving lethal injection
to infants you are a sick and perverted
person if you support that and then I
realized that I'm calling millions of
Americans sick and perverted but so be
it I wish we didn't have all these sick
and perverted people out there but we do
and and and I really mean it I want you
to know how deeply I mean it that if
you're watching this right now you're
listening and you support this and you
think this is OK and you're saying
you're kind of offended now you say well
how dare you call me sick and perverted
oh well yeah that's what I'm calling you
because
that's what you are I wish you weren't
that I wish you were a better person
than you are but right now you're just
not a good person because good people
don't support giving lethal injection to
babies you know and I feel like I'm I'm
setting the bar pretty low here that's
not a high bar to get over I mean if you
can't even clear that bar of not
supporting the lethal injection for
infants then I mean there's nothing I
could do for you're just not a good
person but there's still hope for you
and I pray for you but you just you need
to let go of this horrible horrible
ideology that you're clinging to all
right here's another story from from The
Daily wire Amanda had this one too I get
like half my stories from Amanda in case
you hadn't noticed she reports soon
after Native American activist Nathan
Phillips confronted high school boys
from Covington Catholic in front of
Lincoln Memorial he reportedly led a
protest of about 20 fellow native
activists attempting to crash the
Basilica of the National Shrine of the
Immaculate Conception Saturday evening
mass according to a catholic news agency
while chanting and playing ceremonial
drums a group of Native American rights
activists reportedly led by Nathan
Phillips attempted on January 19th to
enter Washington DC's Basilica during
the mass the group of 20 demonstrators
was stopped by shrine security as it
tried to enter the church during its
5:15 vigil mass so Nathan Phillips now
this is what we were told that Nathan
Phillips that while he was you know he
was just trying to intervene and and
restore peace and order and everything
like that well then he goes in he and he
tries to barge into a church as I've
been saying for four days now Nathan
Phillips is a fraud and a bully and an
agitator an instigator and nothing more
Phillips inserted himself into a tense
situation where children were being
taunted and mocked by grown men and
rather than coming to their defense
which would have been the good and
heroic thing to do rather than doing
he gets in their face he invades their
space and starts playing the drum in
their faces and then he's not even
satisfied because after that incident he
goes and tries to invade a church with
this guy's desperate for attention he's
desperate for controversy he's trying to
provoke everybody but of course before
he went and tried to invade the church
the the first thing he did is he went to
the media and he blatantly lied about
the kids he said that they surrounded
him they wouldn't let him leave video
evidence proves that's a lie he said
they chanted build the wall which again
video evidence contradicts he tried to
provoke them apparently and when he
wasn't able to provoke them he just went
and defamed them instead kind of as a
plan-b
and you might want to think you know if
you if you hadn't heard about the story
you just saw all that you might say well
you know maybe the guy's having a bad
day his behavior was certainly bizarre
and dishonest and despicable
and manipulative but you know maybe
he'll think better of it in the morning
he'll apologize
not so much while while his lies have
resulted in death threats and bomb
scares so much so that the school had to
shut down for a day and these kids now
live in fear of physical reprisals while
all that has gone on philips has only
doubled and tripled down on his original
slander he's done the exact opposite of
backpedal or apologize no he's just gone
he's gone further in various interviews
he's called the boys a lynch mob he's
called them beasts he's called them
beastly he's called them scary I remind
you that these boys are getting death
threats and their families are getting
death threats and Nathan Phillips the
wise old elder just continues to pour
gasoline on the fire it's almost as if
he is trying to get these boys hurt or
worse now the media continues to tell us
that Nathan Phillips is just this kind
old man who want he wants peace and
understanding and harmony well he's got
a really funny way of showing it doesn't
it
in fact originally he was offered an
opportunity to come and sit down and
break bread with the with the kids and
have a dialogue and he turned it down
and then he hinted in the in the next
breath that he that he thinks maybe they
should be expelled
so he's offered the chance to meet with
them and he say no you know what
let's expel them first and then we'll
talk of course now he's he's saying that
okay you know I will meet with them but
he's only gonna meet with them if it
means that he that they sit down and he
stands and he delivers a lecture on
cultural appropriation so he's willing
to come and lecture them but as far as
the dialogue no he's got no interest in
that and then kind of the the cherry on
the sundae Phillips yesterday was
interviewed by I think by the newspaper
in Detroit I believe and he said that
the black Israelites who started this
whole thing by yelling racial slurs and
so on he said that yeah they were saying
some harsh things but he says some of it
was true okay mr. Phillips which parts
were true the parts were they called
Native Americans totem pole worshipers
was that part sure did you even know
they said that or were they shouted the
F words you know a slur word for it for
gay people was was that the true part or
were they were shouting racial slurs at
a black student at the school and saying
that his white friends are gonna harvest
his organs it was that the true part or
where they called the kids incest babies
and future school shooters Nathan
Phillips has taken the side of a vowed
racists who verbally assaulted a bunch
of children so whatever credibility he
had up until that point which he had
none is now gone so he's now in the
negative he's like he's racking up
overdraft penalties right now in the in
his credibility account this is just you
know the media has certainly canonized
some absurdly unworthy characters in the
past but this may be the most glaringly
unworthy Saint yet to be canonized by
the by the media he is no hero he is no
champion
peace he is a bully plain and simple
that's all he is he's just a he's just a
bad person you know and by the way think
about think about what the yeah I'm just
putting this together in my head but
think about this think about what the
left has done just over the last say
like three days so they started the week
slandering and defaming and smearing a
bunch of high school kids and now with
this the passage of this abortion law in
New York they're celebrating the mass
murder of infants I mean this is just
this is just cartoonishly evil so much
so that if you're on that side and
you're doing this
hey like how do you not just catch your
your reflection in the mirror for a
minute and look at yourself and say wow
I am evil this is evil what I'm doing do
you ever stop and say that to yourself
alright one other thing I learned to
mention before we get to some of your
emails this is not as I'm not important
at all actually but and I don't know why
I even still pay attention to this but
Oscar nominations were announced so the
the Oscar ceremony which has no host and
which nobody will watch and nobody cares
about still they announced who they they
have nominated for a Best Picture and I
really think and this is saying
something I think it's the the weakest
collection of Best Picture nominees
maybe ever and there have been some
really weak categories especially
recently but hey now I don't have the
list in front of me they nominated a
Black Panther a movie vice which is just
a kind of an absurd hit piece on Dick
Cheney black Klansmen Green Green book
and there were a couple others in there
now what makes it so what makes it so
weak and so bad because it's one thing
if well you've got a weak
you've got some weak
Best Picture nominees but also there
really weren't any good movies that came
out this year and so then what you got
to give the award to somebody although I
personally you know I personally think
there should be here's where nobody wins
Best Picture it's it's sort of like with
with the Hall of Fame with very these
various Hall of Fame's like especially
the Basketball Hall of Fame or football
of Fame where they feel like every year
they have to induct new people into the
Hall of Fame which kind of diminishes
the value of the Hall of Fame because
then you end up with people who are you
know who are good but don't rise to the
level of historically great there should
be many years in a row where just nobody
makes it into the Hall of Fame because
there hasn't been anyone that good and
there should be years where nobody where
the Academy says you know what we can't
do an award ceremony this year because
nobody you know just they weren't there
what they really weren't any great
movies this year guys so check back next
year but this year there were some great
movies first man was was a truly great
moving powerful movie also a movie that
was subject to absolutely absurd and
unwarranted criticism and controversy
over the stupid issue of the American
flag even though the American flag is
featured in that movie plenty it's a
very patriotic movie the only thing they
don't show is they the the one
particular scene where he actually
plants the flag on the moon they don't
show that
now they do show the flag waving on the
moon they just don't show the moment
where he puts it there which who cares
because do you know what they show
instead they show they show Armstrong
leaving a keepsake on the moon from his
from his young daughter who had died of
cancer years before which I didn't even
know he did that but the movie is is
much more focused on the personal story
of this man and what he went through to
achieve this amazing thing much more
focused on him on a personal level than
it is focused on kind of the geopolitics
or the whole or the sort of the bigger
picture and I think that makes it really
a powerful movie it is a movie called
first man
it's not called first country
although we were the first country but
it's focused on the man more than the
country and I think that he deserves
that anyway because he is the one who
achieved this thing so that's a great
movie it was basically shut out wasn't
nominate for anything quiet place
another great movie it's it's a horror
movie that actually manages to have some
substance to it it actually has suspense
it is legitimately scary but without
resorting to gore or to cheap kind of
jump scares or anything so it's a it is
a it is a horror movie with some
substance and depth to it and it also
features a great kind of father heroic
father figure type of character which
maybe is why it was shut out you know
the Academy doesn't go for that these
days so those are two great movies that
were shut out and instead we have
instead they nominate a stupid comic
book movie I mean we're living in an
idiocracy folks in case you haven't
noticed all right finally let's check
the Inbox
if you want to send me a message comment
question death wish you can email Matt
Walsh show at gmail.com Matt Walsh show
at gmail.com Steven writes I have to say
I'm amazed that some of the hate mail
you get the other amazing part is that
it's from people who apparently take
time to watch the show I don't know why
anyone would find it valuable to listen
continually to something they hate and
then take time to email you telling you
how much they hate you it's like going
to a sushi restaurant when you don't
like sushi
over and over and over and over
nonetheless I listen to your show
regularly and I like the thought that
goes into it Steven Thank You Steven
don't be amazed though this is something
that everyone in my line of work deals
with and we're all perplexed by it we
expected okay so we're not surprised but
as far as the psychology of a person who
would sit down and listen or read
someone that they can that they hate or
follow them on social media or whatever
well the psychology of that is a mystery
to me I think it's a mystery to most of
us now
it's one thing to read or follow or
watch someone you disagree with but
respect now that makes a lot of sense
that's a that's a good and healthy thing
to do and we should all be doing that I
think it's a good challenge for all of
us if you know you should try to come up
with a couple of people who you
fundamentally disagree with on a very
deep level but yet you respect their
opinion and their perspective and so
you'll read some of what they write and
watch whatever they do and you know kind
of follow them a little bit you should
have a few people like that because I
think it helps challenges your views a
little bit helps to make you a more
well-rounded person so for instance I've
probably seen every Christopher Hitchens
speech I've seen most of his debates
I've read one of his books I've read a
lot of his articles I think it was
brilliant insightful incredibly witty I
think it was a kind of a joy to read and
listen to but I disagree with him on a
on a deep and fundamental level but so
that's one thing but to religiously
follow somebody that you despise and who
you don't respect and whose point of
view you you have you know you don't you
don't even take into account and you
have no appreciation for well that I
can't relate to that that doesn't make
any sense there are plenty of people in
media who I don't really respect and I
can't stand and I don't appreciate their
opinion I think that they're just stupid
and shallow and their perspective is
relatively worthless so you know what I
do I don't not gonna watch them not
gonna listen to them why would I but I
think some people are so empty inside
and so lost and just so hollow and
spiritually shriveled up that this is
the only thing that makes them feel live
to to hate to stew gleefully in their
own hatred is the only thing that brings
them a thrill in life and so it's pretty
sad Norman says do you think Satanists
should be allowed to display sculptures
in public places alongside Christian
crosses or nativities why or why not
also should Satanists be allowed to give
talks lectures at public schools if
Christians are allowed to host events at
public schools also thanks love your
work so me this is an easy question I
know this is one of these things that's
supposed to be hard to adjudicate it's
an easy easy answer for me
and you hear about these atheist group
or Satanist groups maybe that's kind of
the same thing you hear about these
Satanist groups I want to put up a
satanic monument or something at a town
square in response to some sort of
judeo-christian monument that's up well
listen if there's a town out there that
is predominantly populated by Satanists
and they want to have a monument in
their town square and in their
courthouse and wherever else declaring
their Satanism and worshipping Satan is
Satan then I say yeah go for it not only
do they have the right to do that but I
would prefer if they did you know
because if I'm if I'm moving or
something or if I'm looking to get a
timeshare in some particular town and
it's 60% populated by Satanists I would
prefer if they announce that fact and
made it clear so if there if I you know
going through the town looking at
apartments and and I see a big monument
to Satan right there in the town square
I'll say okay well you know this will
not be this isn't the town for me so
yeah if I'm a big believer in
subsidiarity I'm a big believer in
keeping things as local as possible I'm
a believer in local jurisdiction so if
there is a town like that out out there
somewhere a Satanist town then yeah they
should be able to put satanic stuff
everywhere and all the rest of us will
just stay the hell away no pun intended
the problem though is that in all of
these cases that you hear about where
they're trying to put a satanic monument
in the town square or in the courthouse
or whatever in every single case it is
it is a or in most the cases I can think
of it is some outside group that is
trying to do this to prove a point
it's not this it's not coming from
within the town and so that I oppose if
a town is mostly Christian and then some
satanic group from seven
States away says we want to put a
satanic monument there well of course
they should be allowed to do that they
don't they're not even from the town
that doesn't represent the views of the
town from Preston he says Matt I've been
a big fan of yours for many years I used
to use your articles for current events
in high school I even listened to your
podcast when you were on the blaze I
recently got married back in November
and really respect your views on
marriage and family what are some bits
of advice you would give to have a happy
and successful marriage
Preston congratulations I'm no marriage
expert or guru I've only been married
for seven years I don't think I'm in the
spot right now where I can even give
advice if I were to offer one thing I'll
offer this just because it's obvious and
it won't blow your mind but here's
something that when I was married I
didn't realize would be so important and
that is and that is gratitude I know
that it's obvious that's the point but
sometimes the most obvious things are
the things that we can overlook so big
you got to be grateful for your wife
verbally openly obviously grateful
appreciate what she does show that you
know this show that you care and I was
talking to your wife I would say the
same thing appreciate your husband be
grateful for him notice what he does I
just think there are so many in so many
unhappy marriages and so many failing
and failed marriages this is the theme
you hear over and over again I know
everybody says well money and all this
stuff is what is what can ruin marriages
no I think if you actually listen to
what these people are saying so often
this is the theme that comes up so they
didn't notice me he didn't appreciate
what I was doing I was doing this I was
doing that they never noticed so on and
so forth now of course in a marriage
it's like you don't you don't want to be
doing everything in hopes of being
appreciated and being noticed but if
you're never appreciated and never
noticed it takes toll on you after a
while and I think it'll destroy your
marriage so that's something to think
about Kris says love the show Matt do
you think that the older Democrats in
Congress see the irony that their
freshman colleagues that they can't
control are a product of their own
failed entitlement and victimhood
policies or do you think that this is
what they're hoping for no I'm
sure they don't notice the irony Chris
but I think that's a very excellent
point thank you for raising it Katie
says hi Matt I heard you say that modern
sitcoms are aggressively stupid I agree
but here's my question what do you think
are the funniest shows on television I
don't know about right now I don't watch
sitcoms right now but the office the
American office seasons one through four
and a half I think that is the that
right there is the funniest chunk of
television ever put on you know on the
American airwaves and then it fell off
rapidly from there but that's what I
would that would be my vote
let's see Kelsey says Matt I appreciate
your show I know your children are young
but I was wondering how do you feel
about Christians sending their kids to
public colleges I'm a disabled veteran
and my kids have the opportunity to get
grants for California state colleges I
just don't know if that education is
worth our time thanks to your opinion
Kelsey thanks for your service and your
sacrifice first of all you know this is
the city this is just here's here's what
I say about generally my opinion is it's
best to avoid public colleges but you
have to make decision that's best for
you and for your for your kids
especially my main thing whether it's
public college or private college or no
college I think the main thing and this
should not be a controversial point of
view but the main thing is as long as a
kid has some concept some vague general
concept of what they want to do with
their life and how they're going to use
their education and sort of what the
point of it is going to be for them then
if they have that in mind then it's
easier to decide where they're gonna go
to college or if they're gonna go at all
I think the problem is so often when we
just toss our kids into college even
though they have no idea what they want
to do in there with their life they have
no idea what their skills are no idea
what their passions are which just shows
you that's a failure of the public
school system that you can have these
kids that go through 13 years of formal
education they get to the age of 18
years old and so many of them have no
idea what
care about what their views are what
their priorities are what their goals
are no clue and I know it's true that 18
you don't have to have it all figured
out but but I mean you should have some
general idea of what you're good at and
you know some kind of vague idea of who
you are as a person and so many kids
don't that's it that's a failure of the
public school education system but if a
kid has that in mind then it's easier to
say okay I'm gonna go here for this
reason I'm gonna major in this this is
the best place to go here's my plan but
if they have no idea at all then what I
say all the time is there's no reason
for them to go they could just go get a
job they can move out live in an
apartment on their own foot pay some
bills you know experience adult life and
then as they figure it out then they
could go to college or they may discover
that they don't need college for what
they want to do with their life and they
can spare themselves the debt and
everything else but there's no real
downside it's it's not a race so I don't
know if they answer your questions but
that's what I that's what I would say
Cory says Matt when you first started I
hated you but over time I have to admit
I've come to still hate you thank you
for thank you for that finally Megan
says Matt on Twitter I saw you talking
about becoming a beekeeper were you
serious about that I'm absolutely
serious I'm gonna order the bee not a
beekeeper yet but I'm ordering bees
I've got mostly I've got the bee suit
and I've got the frames the hives and so
I'm gonna start my beekeeping journey
this year why am i becoming a big just
because you know because why not number
one why not be a beekeeper I also think
that I want to have a hobby that has
nothing at all to do with this and
nothing to do with anything that you
know politics or anything like that
and also think that bees are fascinating
they really are if you read about besom
if you just go watch like a documentary
on bees or read about them these are
fascinating creatures who are also
crucial to the to humanity and to
agriculture but just one example of the
fact I could go on for 30 minutes about
bees I won't do it maybe someday I will
one fascinating thing
B's is you know bees can find sources of
of pollen and nectar that are miles away
you may wonder well how do they find
though how do they find the flowers and
vegetation everything
well what they'll do is they'll send out
scouts to go and find you know some
patch of flowers somewhere in a field
you know and then that the bees will
come back and now they have to
communicate to the other bees where
those flowers are and the flowers could
be two and half miles away and so they
have this little dance that they'll do
where they wiggle their body in a circle
and they're essentially communicating
the coordinates to the other bees who
are standing there watching and then
they all go and they find the flower I
mean that is fascinating and it shows
you God's design in nature as well which
is maybe one of the reasons I like it
alright well leave it there thanks for
watching everybody thanks for listening
Godspeed